normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government let me
jump to the story from CNN ladies and
gentlemen we got him house oversight GOP
released document showing payments made
by Hunter Biden to his dad documents say
they were for a car uh I I wonder why CN
added that last bit documents say they
were for a car as if that changes the
fact that Hunter Biden's business was
sending Joe Biden money you know it's
like but it was for a car I'm like like
oh so is that what the corruption was
paying for I don't know what your point
is but uh it wasn't that much money it
was
$1,380 for over four months so I think
it it didn't was it four months but yes
he was directly paying him and so here
here's what I here's what I worry about
sure it's big you know Joe Biden
repeatedly lied about having no
involvement oh come on dude you're
getting reimbursement from his company
not only did he lie about whether he
talked to any of his business Associates
he said he had nothing to do with his
business and now it's you did talk to
his people and you actually receed
direct payments from his business for
which you are directly involved and
there's emails showing you being
directly involved y'all you're lying
here's the problem the House GOP seems
to be dripping this one out so slowly
none of these things are landing like
this story you know I see lot people are
like oh hey look at this but it's like
oh okay I don't know one payment yo if
they came out with one big hit and said
here is all the proof and slamed it on
the table and then maybe H back a little
bit they would they would it would land
much much better maybe that's the plan
for going to 2024 maybe the October
surprise will be the big Syndicate org
chart of Joe Biden on top with the red
yarn going from person to person but
when they do these stories it's like
yeah okay we we got him you know he's
sending money directly to his dad from
his company not personally it's still
such a thin sliver of a story I don't
think it hits that hard
I don't think it hits I don't think it
hits at all right I I'm not I'm not even
convinced like if you had some kind of
significant evidence of significant
payments even that at this point I feel
like would be kind of brushed under the
rug by by the the corporate media at
least it would have to be something that
was absolutely devastating to not be
just ignored I really think that the the
the the you know corporate media is just
they're not going to report on it not
going to treat anything like it's a
serious I I kind ofation law I kind of
think this is all just a mistake for the
Republicans to be honest no nobody ever
cared about Joe Biden nobody in 2020
cared about Joe Biden nobody in 2019
cared about Joe Biden Joe Biden could
literally walk onto stage and just take
a dump right on the floor and walk out
and it would change nothing his approval
rating is in the gutter because he's a
bad leader and this country is facing
serious hardship but no one's paying
attention to Joe Biden the man nobody
thinks he's capable or competent nobody
wants to vote for him they want to vote
against someone else so when when the
Republicans come out and they're like oh
look what the bidens are doing regular
people are like yeah we don't like him
either but we like we we'll vote for him
so he it's it's it's funny because Trump
had that famous line you know he could
shoot somebody on Fifth Avenue yeah well
Joe Biden could take a dump on on the
middle of the Oval Office floor with
live cameras rolling and it would change
nothing there's so there's been so many
dumps on the floor tonight I mean oh
yeah yeah with the with the all that
talk with Gavin Nome know a lot of poop
lot of a lot a lot taking a dump on the
floor you know just in front of a bunch
of people and but my point is this when
you combine my my point by combining all
of it is Yo default liberal types
literally don't care what you do they
don't they really don't again like I'll
reference like you know one of my
buddies in in California we were talking
and he's like you know one of the things
that I'm really sick of hearing is like
you know someone will be like oh well
this guy did this but that guy did this
and da d d and he's like I don't care
put than than prosecute them all and I
think that that's the way that a lot of
people feel but they don't feel strongly
enough about Prosecuting people that are
ostensibly on their their team or their
side to actually want to to actually get
their representatives to do anything we
are so pasted there being a system of
laws in this country just it's not even
a point to bring it up right we know we
know Joe Biden did it we know what he
did we know about the payment we know
about the phone calls we know about the
flying to Ukraine we know why he did it
Victor shokin has sworn testimony you
can lay it all on the floor we know the
crimes are being committed we know that
on January 6 on one side of the building
police allowed people in pulled the
barricades aside fanned them in opened
the doors waved them in took selfies
with them and uh gave them tours and we
know that BLM in Atlanta set fire to a
Wendy's and were given a slap on the
wrist and no jail time they were given
probation and community service we know
that the Federal federal government has
not charged the far- leftists who
stormed the government facilities
outside of Atlanta at stop cop City and
it's a state level charge only there the
the the idea that there is Law and Order
in this country so when I say you know
Civil War people need to start waking up
to what's going on okay the January
Sixers the people who are riding and
violent I get it give them criminal
charges but they just arrested a guy
recently uh he he had flown to Nashville
for lady Ballers flew back they arrested
him on the spot mhhm even though he had
already answered questions 2 years ago
and he his story is that I think he
stood at the foyer of one of the doors
they opened and filmed and then left
didn't matter they came after him anyway
and they're going to get every single
person didn't he work at the daily
callers un likee that I think this guy
was a republican Republican uh uh Party
official or something okay yeah the
point
is if you are on the right the feds are
coming for you there is no semblance of
justice and they don't care if you think
there is or isn't it's meaningless they
are wielding power and violence against
people raiding their homes if if you
know I guess you can tell me what you
think Civil War is because I suppose if
if nothing's being done to combat the
corruption the Republicans are super
concerned about Joe Biden getting
payments and not uh so much with January
6 you know now we're hearing that um
they're going to release the remainder
of the j6 footage but they're going to
blur faces and of course everyone's
saying yeah to protect feds yeah of
course because the feds already have all
the all the videos yep
so here we go there there's there's no
there's no functioning system of laws we
were swatted 15 times last year nothing
was done they never found out Marg no we
know we know we know we we we have a
general idea of who it was and how it
happened and everything lined up
perfectly and no matter how many
agencies we call and no matter how much
evidence we submit they just laugh and
say no so margorie Taylor green just did
an interview with Tucker guy released
today or yesterday maybe she had the
same thing they can't find out who uh
who swatted her they won't give her any
information well to be fair her
circumstance and ours are very very
different but can't they find out who it
is she I mean she brought up that the
unmasked Carter page right it is fair it
is fair to say that properly done it is
it is damn near impossible to Trek
there's there's there's there's
automated systems through routers
through through Russia through through
not only that I mean you could take a
yagi Wi-Fi antenna from an apartment
building point it at at a Wendy's a mile
away connect to a public Wi-Fi and then
call from Skype yeah and they're going
to be like they're going to say it was
traced to a Wendy's but how do we figure
out who who it was and all the footage
it's not that easy in our circumstance
we actually have uh uh we actually have
serious evidence meaning that some of
the addresses that got swatted are not
public record they're not even they're
not even in government record you can't
even search for them so only a few
people would know it only only three
people uhhuh and we're like here you go
and they were just like eh and I'm like
dude only three people have like I don't
even think it was three people I think
it was one one one person and they're
like me and I said it just stops they
don't care we even had uh FBI was
involved and they said don't care I kind
of the the bomb the fake bombs that were
sent to us they didn't care I'm like
someone sent mock
bombs and to shank re weager or whatever
his name is no no and they sent that
robots to our to our studio and we are
like we have information on how this is
happening and they're like we don't care
and I'm like you guys had to come out
for this and they're like never called
us once never asked us didn't care and
so a lot of people actually started
posting like it's the feds doing it to
you and I'm like well I don't know about
all that but I can tell you they
certainly like that it's happening
because they're they're corrupt evil
lazy or combination of all of it can you
talk timy you said you mentioned Civil
War are you saying that like there's
already one going on against the right
they just haven't recognized it yet well
fifth generational Warfare you can call
whatever you want some people it depends
on your definition of Civil War but if
uh federal law enforcement is expanded
weaponized and being used to Target
political opponents you can call it a
soft coup I don't know you can call
whatever you want I mean look the the
the the the Biden doj is going after Joe
Biden's rival like the federal
government under Joe Biden is arrest has
arrested and criminally charged his
chief political opponent yeah the
federal government is not supposed to
have an opinion about who the who which
you know which political party is
running the government like they're not
supposed to have a have a say they're
just supposed to say we reflect
whatever the
people they're supposed to be you know a
reflection of the will of the people not
they're not supposed to dictate what
people should think it' be cool if they
renounced their party party affiliation
when they got into the federal
government oh that doesn't mean anything
it would just be nice to look at look
you can you could I think there's one
strong argument as to why we're not in a
civil war because there's only one side
fighting MH Republicans what what should
they be doing uh they should be filing
criminal charges at the state level uh
you you could have a small dist
District Ada file criminal charges start
an investigation over tons of stuff
related to Federal Finance uh uh like at
the state level so if there is a state
campaign happening in in in your redate
you can start looking into donations
given James O'Keefe uncovered a lot of
questionable practices in in donations
James O'Keefe goes goes to people's
doors and says you made 10,000 donations
you were making three donations a day
and they're like no I wasn't where's a
single Republican prosecutor to be like
okay it's time to to launch an
investigation to this they don't do
anything meanwhile you've got the
federal government literally trying to
put the front runner for the Republican
party in prison so maybe it's not a
civil war maybe it's just I don't know a
coup I agree that there are legal ways
to attempt to you know Rectify but I'm
kind of with you that like the law has
become so abused in this country in the
last 110 years pretty much since the
soft coup of the Federal Reserve and
these Jackal High jackal jackal Island
dudes you know JP Morgan and friends
that it's like accept it and just change
the minds of the people so that whoever
has the control of the mob is going to
be good well that's the thing I I I I
think it's important to mention that uh
we're winning and that it's because
we've focused on cultural issues and
less so politics so while it is
frustrating to see Republicans not doing
anything the groundwork being laid by
say rumble by I mean Elon Musk
especially with buying x with uh
parallel economy this is essentially Dan
bunin know this is Rumble several others
launching a financial transaction system
which we use for
timcast.net while it's frustrating to
watch a lot of the stuff happen I think
it's important to mention too they can
keep trying the stuff but I think acts
of force prove their
desperation the only way to stop Trump
is to just cross the line and try to
have him
arrested that that precipitates their
their their their fall you know I I the
first that this whole parallel economy
thing got really really real for me was
this past week when uh the lady Ballers
trailer came out it's it looks like a it
looks like a Hollywood level production
movie right like it's it looks really
good the the the previews funny um I
don't know it's like we're finally
figuring things out how to make it
really work and take it to that highest
quality level I don't even I I I who yes
but we should say who cares Hollywood
can go make their weird Marvel Marvels
that bombs worst worst Marvel movie ever
less than the Hulk which one is this the
new one that just came out the Marvel oh
oh the Marvel yeah yeah it it made less
money than the Hulk did and that was
considered to be like the black sheep of
the MCU and now the Marvels did worse
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 pm
and become a member over at timcast.net